I'll tell you what I'll tell you why  because his mating strategy strategy is  if we go back to our biology right it's  to screw as many people as possible and  ensure paternity our our mating strategy  is to get resources from a guy so you  get your mating strategy and and  commitment from the guy so you get your  mating strategy fulfilled and he has to  deal with someone else's kid nah like  you cheated on him by not waiting for  marriage okay to have a child  by itself so so I I think you you  basically cheated on him by not giving  him Purity and youth I mean you can't  give him people you can't give him wait  wait you can't give him Purity if you  have a child you can that's true and so  it's like if you don't offer that why  would you expect monogamy